ted wheeler is speaking
um i think this is yesterday
um in the wake of riots by antifa
throughout i think it was north or
northeast portland um
on new year's eve and including attacks
on the federal buildings downtown in
downtown which is the
northwest or southwest whatever right
across the river um
and you know it's just it's just so much
of the same
garbage that's been happening since the
end of may almost almost uninterrupted
um and should we just go on or should we
let him show it
um yeah why don't you show it okay
my good faith efforts at de-escalation
have been met with ongoing violence
and even scorn from radical antifa
and anarchists in response
it will be necessary to use additional
tools
and to push the limits of the tools we
already have
to bring the criminal destruction and
violence
to an end lawlessness
and anarchy come at great expense
and with great risk to the future of our
community
it's time to push back harder against
those who are set on destroying
our community and to take more risks
in fighting lawlessness in closing
once again i condemn anyone
who engages in violence or criminal
destruction
no matter what their ideology
all right so that is our mayor
finally figuring out which way is up
it's about
time it's amazingly overdue which you
know one does not want to punish the man
for
finally realizing that he's going to
have to enforce the goddamn law against
people who are
willfully destroying things in pursuit
of at best a
nonsensical utopian vision of portland
and
how the rest of the world should look
yeah now i did notice
and i thought it was particularly
delightful that
in his statement he says my
good faith efforts a de-escalation had
been met with
ongoing violence and even
scorn right as if violence weren't bad
enough
there has been scorn my but i think he's
actually
surprised and actually a little hurt
that they don't love him for all of his
eyes
he is they never will no it's they they
they won't they will they will never
come to adopt you ted
no they won't and hopefully that message
sticks because if i am not mistaken he
is in the process of regrowing a pair
i mean he is let us hope yes he has
landed
on his seasonally appropriate grounds
breeding spot and he's
regrown a pair he is regrowing a pair it
will no longer be true if this
process continues that the only thing
about him that is ismail is his pronouns
all right i don't know why i said it but
he does have three pronouns i've never
seen three pronouns before he declares
three pronouns not just the usual two
you gotta be well covered he him his yep
he does so anyway this is uh good news
that he will be
enforcing the law um he does i mean if
you think you will well let's put it
this way
i think that this state might actually
be fed up i think at this point he has
realized that there's no
there's nothing down this road right and
it is amazing to though i mean these
people
literally lit his building on fire
with his neighbors present right and he
apologized to the neighbors
and moved he moved i mean i think
apologizing to the neighbors made good
sense but
um actually i'm not even sure he
apologized i think he might have
apologized to antifa
he did okay jack says he apologized to
the neighbors but in any case
um as residents of portland it is about
time it is
amazing that it took so long to get here
let us hope that he does a good and
competent job he does say the right
things in that clip
about the fact that um we will need to
avail ourselves of new technologies and
apply the ones we've got
hopefully it's done well but um that
sounds ominous
okay it does but nonetheless you know
you have
ongoing lawlessness obviously there's no
choice here
so um well i mean they could have fully
availed themselves for the technologies
they had from the beginning well in fact
i think that would have worked he kept
taking them off the table
exactly yeah yeah so it's uh yeah uh
it is good news hopefully it works out
you